basically what we're doing I can show
you this week here because it'll be easy
to see easier to see than a small week
usually you don't claim me to weed that
is this big we're trying to get them
when they just emerge but if you look at
this thing we passed the flame over
pretty quickly and you can see it's
already starting to wilt down it's not
like charred to charcoal or burn or
anything but when I pinch one of the
leaves I can see it leaves a really dark
spot where I can tell that the cells the
plant cells have ruptured because what
has happened is the flame has heated up
the water in the plant cells enough so
that the cell wall expands and bursts
and so this weed will wilt and die you
know if we come back in a couple hours
and look at it what you're trying to do
you can either use flame eating for a
stale bedding technique meaning that you
know letting the weeds in the top one or
two inches of the soil sort of express
themselves over the period of one or two
weeks and you can come through the flame
leader and sort of boiled them off the
bed top so that's creating a stale seed
bed and after a couple of passes like
that a lot of the weeds that are on the
top layer of the soil have already
germinated so you have it's stale
the main application that we would use
it for is will seed a crop into a bed
and before the crop emerges we'll pass
the flame leader leader over the surface
of the soil crop is under the soil so it
stays protected but the weeds that are
on the top of the bed are plain weeded
and then the crop emerges up into a
clean seed bed